Of course we don't just see ambiguity
in propositions, we also it in words.
David, can you think of
ambiguity in a word?
>> To go back to our throw example,
I might say I was wondering why the ball
was getting bigger and then it hit me.
The word hit is ambiguous because it
could either mean occur or strike.
It occurred to me why the ball
was getting bigger, or
the ball physically struck me.
Take another example.
It's hard to explain
puns to kleptomaniacs
because they always
take things literally.
The humor here is that take could either
mean interpret, as in they always
interpret things literally, or it could
mean physically pick up and remove.
As in they literally always take things.
In fact, many puns derive their
humor from the fact that a word in
the sentence can play two different
roles in the sentence at once.
And the sentence still makes sense.
>> Did you know that I was going to
say this will be much fun?
The goal going forward is to look at how
agents will resolve some ambiguities.
When one correct meaning, and
only one correct meaning is possible.
Not however, that we might build
our character with a bit of humor.
Perhaps one form of humor is when
a single sentence can be made to fill
multiple grammatical simultaneously.